Metro Police this afternoon are
investigating an early morning murder in
the southwest Valley a mother allegedly
killed by her daughter she's now under
arrest this happened down in the
Mountain's Edge neighborhood June Flower
Drive near Jones and Cactus Candace
Charles is live there at the scene with
what took place Candice good afternoon
and so do the police continue to
investigate when they arrived a woman
was dead the victim of a homicide I'm
told her daughter arrested in California
and neighbors say there have been other
incidents here
I don't really expected to go there for
for there to be a scene like this this
community waking up to police lights and
crime scene tape I don't know what
caused an altercation what made it
escalate to this point around 2 30
Wednesday morning 9-1-1 dispatch got a
call from a woman saying her mother was
dead then the call disconnected when
they arrived they found a 62 year old
woman dead we then started looking for
the vehicle and the daughter CHP was
able to locate stop her take her to
custody about 5 a.m this morning in
Barstow California as neighbors started
to hear the news some tell me they were
shocked but that this was not the first
time police were here she was in
handcuffs in front of the house uh
fire trucks came I'm guessing she she
started to fight
our neighbors said that that incident
happened a couple of months ago we have
reached out to Metro see if we can get a
little bit more information on that
we're still waiting to hear back and of
course this is a developing story so as
we learn more we'll be sure to bring you
more so stick with us right here on air
online on social for the latest for now
I'm Candace Charles 8 News Now